we start with a bizarre case involving a
wanted fugitive who was mistakenly
released from a local hospital now
sheriff's deputies are trying to track
him down and want the public's help
the night county sheriff's office says
this all started last saturday when
35-year-old larry avila was involved in
a pursuit on his motorcycle
deputies say avila who has warrants for
crimes involving theft stolen property
and narcotics was hurt during the chase
and taken to a local hospital the
sheriff's office tells 8 news now staff
was supposed to let them know when he
was released so he could be booked into
jail instead he was let go a woman
picked him up and he's on the run again
deputies are asking anyone who knows
anything about avila or the woman he was
with to contact them he's described as
five foot four
165 pounds with brown hair and brown
eyes
if you have any information on where
avila could be or can identify the woman
with him contact the nye county
sheriff's office the number you see here
on your screen 775-751-7000